[Musique]
je m'appelle jonathan les rênes j'ai 38
ans et avant j'étais un véritable cancre
du bonheur en grandissant je pensais que
le bonheur ça allait venir avec le
succès et alors il ya treize ans j'ai
intégré un grand cabinet d'avocats à
wall street
vous représentez des grandes
institutions financières j'étais
extrêmement bien payé j'avais une belle
situation mais pourtant je n'étais pas à
ma place c'était malheureux dépressif et
ge perdait progressivement le goût à la
vie il ya 7 ans j'ai décidé de tout
arrêter
laisser ma carrière d'avocat derrière
moi et de me lancer dans une grande
recherche sur le bonheur parce que la
question qui m'anime c'est comment ça se
fait que ça fait cinq mille ans qu'on
joue à ce jeu de la civilisation quand
cent mille ans on a appris à envoyer des
êtres humains dans l'espace n'a pris à
reproduire des animaux par le clonage on
a appris à créer des machines qu'ils
pensent mais pourtant on n'a fait
absolument aucun progrès sur le bonheur
en juger le nombre de dépressions
le nombre de suicides le spleen ambiant
on aurait même régressé sur le bonheur
est ce que j'ai découvert pendant cette
exploration cette recherche sur la
science du bonheur c'est que le bonheur
il n'est pas à l'extérieur il à
l'intérieur et que l'ennemi numéro un du
bonheur c'est un phénomène qu'on peut
appeler la tyrannie du mental et ce
phénomène il a été particulièrement bien
résumé je trouve par un journaliste
américain du nom de dan harris qui a
deux ans a publié un livre sur le
bonheur qu'il a appelée comment je suis
devenu 10% plus heureux mais qui selon
ses dires il aurait voulu appeler la
voix dans ma tête est une [ __ ]
alors est ce que ça vous parle je suis
désolé du terme mais moi c'est un terme
qui m'a parlé véritablement parce que
effectivement on a tous dans la tête
un petit dictateur un tyran une [ __ ]
qui nous crée des problèmes qui nous dit
que ça va pas et mon but aujourd'hui
c'est partager avec vous les techniques
pour transformer ce tyran en outil de
bonheur mais pour ça déjà il faut qu'on
soit d'accord sur ce qu'est le bonheur
il faut qu'on soit d'accord sur
qu'est-ce qu'on va affecter parce que le
bonheur ça veut dire plein de choses
pour plein de personnes pour certaines
personnes le bonheur ça va être de
gravir une montagne alors que ça être
une angoisse pour d'autres personnes
pour certaines personnes le bonheur ça
va être d'être seul sur une plage alors
que ça va être une vision de cauchemar
pour une autre personne
en revanche ce qui est universel et ce
sur quoi on peut se mettre d'accord
c'est la souffrance la souffrance c'est
quoi c'est tout simplement les états
mentaux aînés et émotionnelle négatif
c'est la colère c'est la tristesse c'est
la peur si l'angoissé la culpabilité et
donc on peut tout simplement se mettre
d'accord sur une définition du bonheur
qui est l'absence de souffrance et donc
augmenter le bonheur ça peut être tout
simplement diminuer la souffrance
une autre façon de voir ça c'est par
rapport à l'instant présent le bonheur
c'est l'acceptation de l'instant présent
qui peut aller du neutre à
l'enthousiasmé la joie la souffrance la
résistance à l'instant présent c'est
qu'en dit non à l'ici et maintenant ce
que je voudrais partager avec vous
aujourd'hui c'est comment faire en sorte
d'augmenter nos nombre de moments
d'acceptation et diminuer le nombre de
moments de résistance et pour ça il faut
qu'on puisse mesurer et pour mesurer
quelque chose que je trouve extrêmement
intéressant c'est la constatation qui a
été fait il ya quelques années de ça par
de nombreux psychologues que apparemment
le présent conscient durerait trois
secondes un moment dur et trois secondes
alors c'est une mesure qui peut vous
paraître extrêmement arbitraire et elle
l'est mais néanmoins elle est basée sur
l'observation qu'il ya énormément de
comportement de mammifères qui dure en
moyenne trois secondes
que ce soit le temps qu'un panda mais à
déféquer le temps qu'une girafe mais à
mastiquer de l'herbe
la durée moyenne d'embrassades
d'athlètes olympiques
à la fin d'une épreuve en moyenne 3
secondes alors vous pouvez vous dire oui
mais mes états mentaux émotionnel je
l'éteins les tient plus longtemps que ça
et c'est vrai que nous les adultes on
tient nos états mentaux et émotionnels
plus longtemps que ça mais pourtant
observer des enfants en train de jouer
dans un bac à sable dans une cour de
récréation
il passe du rire aux larmes de l'extase
à la colère de la joie à la frustration
en quelques instants seulement
et ça ça nous montre que nous aussi on a
cette capacité de changer nos états
mentaux et émotionnels
même constat nous paraît difficile et
c'est responsabilisant et si on postule
que dans une vie moyenne en dur 80
années et condor un tiers ça veut dire
qu'on a 500 millions de moments dans la
vie
500 millions d'opportunités d'être dans
l'acceptation ou la résistance à
l'instant présent
peut-être dans le bonheur ou d'être dans
la souffrance est donc maintenant je
vais partager avec vous mes trois anti
sèches du bonheur les trois choses pour
justement augmenter le nombre de moments
de bonheur
quel que soit l'endroit où vous vous
trouvez et contrecarrer cette tyrannie
du mental et en faire un outil de
bonheur et ça s'appelle des antisèches
du bonheur parce que moi je suis un
étudiant du bonheur à plein temps
je sais que vous n'avez pas le temps
d'être des étudiants du bonheur à plein
temps et puis vous avez des quotidiens
qui sont très chargés et ce dont vous
avez besoin c'est des petits trucs qui
sans bouleverser votre quotidien peuvent
complètement changé votre vie et c'est
ça l'idée de ses antisèches elles
suivent le principe dit de pareto qui
nous dit que dans énormément de cas 80%
des conséquences viennent de 20 % des
causes c'est ce principe d'effet de
levier les petites choses qui peuvent
avoir un gros impact et donc ses
antisèches elle tourne autour des trois
aspects de la tyrannie du mental qui
sont premièrement que le mental est
négatif
deuxièmement que le mental est compulsif
et troisièmement que le mental est
intérieure premièrement le mental est
négatif
c'est le phénomène connu sous le nom de
bienne négativité qui nous dit que la
pensée négative voyage plus rapidement
dans le cerveau et qu'elle pèse plus
lourd que la pensée positive
imaginez que je vous fasse 9 compliment
est un reproche
après demain vous allez vous souvenir de
quoi en premier
oui très probablement du reproche et on
est tous comme ça c'est notre
biologiques comme ça on a une machine
régler des problèmes dans la tête c'est
ce qui nous a permis de survivre mais
quand il n'y a plus de problème la
machine elle continue à marcher elle va
créer des problèmes
elle se transforme en machine à créer du
malheur le penseur alexandre jollien ai
dit qu'on a tous toujours un problème du
moment et ça c'est pas à cause des
circonstances extérieures sa cause de
notre biologie on peut se demander mais
alors pourquoi est ce qu'on recherche le
bonheur et on a une machine à créer du
malheur dans la tête et une explication
darwinienne pour ça et cette explication
c'est que notre espèce les homo sapiens
sapiens existe sur terre depuis à peu
près deux cents mille années mais que
sur ces 200 mille années on en a passé à
peu près 195000 à être des bêtes
sauvages dont le seul but était de
survivre à savoir de manger de pas
mourir et que ça fait que 5000 ans qu'on
a changé le logiciel de l'être humain
pour passer de la survie au bonheur le
problème c'est qu'en à peu près 5000 ans
le cerveau a pas eu le temps de changer
et donc on se retrouve aujourd'hui
coincé avec des cerveaux d'animal en
mode survie
maintenant imaginez un animal en mode
survie qui rate un signal positif qui
serait aujourd'hui un compliment mais
qui à l'époque aurait été un fruit sucré
qu'est-ce qu'il a raté juste une
occasion de manger quelque chose de bon
mais s'ils ratent un signal négatif
telles que la présence d'un prédateur
qui serait aujourd'hui leurs proches
eh ben il est mort et c'est pour ça
qu'on a c'est machine à créer du malheur
aujourd'hui dans le cerveau et ça c'est
la mauvaise nouvelle
la bonne nouvelle c'est le phénomène
neurologique 10,2 neuroplasticité qui
nous dit qu'on peut transformer le
cerveau qu'il est comme de la pâte à
modeler le cerveau est composé de
milliards de neurones et à chaque pensée
correspondait aux propres réseaux de
neurones et à chaque fois que j'active
une pensée que je donne de la force à
une pensée je renforce ce réseau de
neurones ne telle sorte que j'augmente
la probabilité que ce réseau de neurones
s'activent automatiquement par lui-même
dans le futur et ça c'est
vraiment important ça nous dit qu'il ya
aucune pensée qui est anodine toute
pensée nous affecte non seulement dans
l'ici et maintenant mais elle envoie un
signal au cerveau s'il te plaît
resserrement une pensée comme ça et donc
toute pensée et soit cercle vertueux
soit cercle vicieux et c'est extrêmement
responsabilisant de comprendre ça est ce
que nous dit la science contemporaine et
c'est le domaine de la psychologie
positive c'est que l'une des choses les
plus importantes pour le bonheur est une
des deux choses les plus importantes que
j'ai personnellement apprises dans ma
recherche sur le bonheur c'est qu'il
faut pratiquer rituellement la gratitude
pour contrecarrer la tyrannie du mental
chaque jour écrire toutes les choses
spécifiques pour lesquelles on est
reconnaissant
la super conversation que j'ai eue avec
mon amie zoé le délicieux sandwichs au
saumon
ce qui compte c'est d'être spécifique et
d'être régulier albert einstein a dit
qu'il n'y a que deux façons de vivre sa
vie l'une en faisant comme si rien
n'était un miracle
l'autre en faisant comme si tout était
un miracle et cette pratique de la
gratitude
elle nous entraîne justement à
redécouvrir les miracles de l'instant
présent
voilà pour la première antisèches le
deuxième aspect de la tyrannie du mental
c'est le fait que le mental est
compulsif il produit en moyenne 60 mille
pensées par jour il nous parle
incessamment du passé du futur ya pas de
bouton on off on peut être sur une plage
on peut être en train de faire l'amour
on peut être en train de manger quelque
chose de délicieux on a toujours
dépenser même qu'on n'en a pas besoin et
la deuxième en tissage que je veux
partager avec vous et qui est la chose
la plus importante que j'ai apprise dans
ces sept années d'exploration du bonheur
et qui beaucoup moins difficile qu'on
croit et ça c'est la pratique de la
méditation et c'est quoi la méditation
comment ça marche et pourquoi
c'est quoi la méditation c'est tout
simplement des exercices de l'attention
sur l'instant présent souvent sur la
respiration camp mais dit on décide
pendant une période prédéterminée qu'on
va ramener son attention l'instant
présent quand irrémédiablement elle va
se perdre dans des pensées parce que la
pensée automatique
c'est cet acte de ramener l'attention
encore et toujours quand elle se perd à
l'instant présent qui est le fondement
la bible de la méditation et qui est une
illustration du cerveau comme on
pourrait muscler nos muscles corporelle
et en faisant ça en fait un pas en
arrière par rapport aux tyrans
à part en arrière par rapport au mental
compulsif ont le regard tourné dans le
vide et du coup on apprend à s'en servir
plutôt que de laisser servir de nous
comme quand ils nous cause du stress
alors comment méditer il pas besoin
d'aller dans un monastère dans un ashram
à l'autre bout du monde
aujourd'hui on peut trouver des
méditations de guider sur internet des
enregistrements qui font même pas 10
minutes vous posez vous appuyez sur
lecture et ça y est vous méditer pour
ressentir les bienfaits
il suffit d'en faire un petit peu chaque
jour il est bien fait ils sont
incroyables il ya une explosion du
nombre d'études sur les bienfaits de la
méditation la méditation à la trois
grands bienfaits elle rend plus heureux
elle rend plus intelligent elle rallonge
la vie rien que ça elle rend plus
heureux dans la mesure où justement
elles nous permettent de mettre une
distance par rapport aux pensées aux
émotions gênante pour pouvoir musclée la
tension et omet l'attention vers du
contenu positif qui va nous faire du
bien
elle rend plus heureux dans la mesure où
elles relâchent de la sérotonine dans le
cerveau des endorphines la dopamine
elle rend plus intelligent dans la
mesure où elle renforce la concentration
elle améliore la mémoire elle stimule la
créativité et l rallonge la vie dans la
mesure où on sait aujourd'hui que la
méditation quand les pratiquer
régulièrement
elle permet de ralentir le
vieillissement des cellules et empêcher
l'arrivée de maladies telles que des
maladies cardiovasculaires et d'ailleurs
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
méditation est si présente est de plus
en plus aujourd'hui dans les hôpitaux
personnellement et c'est pour ça que
celui-ci enthousiaste la méditation ça a
complètement transformé ma vie avant
j'étais colérique j'étais dépressive
j'avais un très mauvais rapport avec moi
même grâce à cette pratique ces dix
minutes même pas par jour j'ai
complètement tout changer j'ai plus
confiance en moi je me souviens de son
mais objet j'ai cherché partout avant je
me souviens de mes rêves la liste est
tellement longue
vous savez au début du 19e siècle il y
avait seulement une minorité de
personnes qui se brosser les dents
régulièrement au début du 20e siècle y
avait seulement une minorité de
personnes qui faisaient du sport
régulièrement et au début du 21e siècle
et seulement une minorité de personne
qui pratique la méditation régulièrement
mais pourtant les générations futures
regarderont notre génération de non mais
dites en deux
même façon que nous on regarde les
anciennes générations qui se brossait
pas les dents qui faisait pas de sport
parce que c'est une hygiène du cerveau
qui est absolument essentiel et dont
véritablement on ne peut pas se passer
le troisième aspect de la tyrannie du
mental c'est le fait que le mental il
est coincé dans la tête
le mental il à l'intérieur on a des
problèmes qui rumine ça tourne en rond
c'est des problèmes qui sont très
simples mais où qui pourrait être simple
si seulement les extérioriser mais
pourtant on les laisse à l'intérieur et
on y voit pas clair si vous voulez c'est
un peu comme la différence entre du
calcul mental et du calcul à l'écrit si
je vous demande de faire 2 143 x 87 et
que vous essayez de faire ça dans la
tête
vous risquez de vous perdre de perdre du
temps de gâcher des moments mais si vous
le mettez à l'écrit en 2 minutes vous
allez réussir à résoudre l'équation
et c'est cette idée d'extérioriser la
pensée pour réussir à mieux voir le
tyran et mieux apprendre à s'en servir
qui à la base de la psychanalyse c'est
ce que freud appelait le ramonage de
cheminée la cure par la parole mais ce
que moi je vais vous dire aujourd'hui
c'est que ça peut être très bénéfique
d'avoir un thérapeute et de se parler
tout seul à voix haute en présence de
quelqu'un de professionnel
mais on peut le faire tout seul c'est ce
que j'appelle sortir les poubelles
mental on peut le faire à l'oral on peut
le faire à l'écrit à l'oral tout
simplement moi ce que je fais et ce que
je conseille de faire c'est quand vous
avez un problème comment j'ai un
problème je me retire et je me fais les
questions et les réponses
alors zhuo c'est quoi le problème est ce
que c'est vraiment si grave que ça
est-ce que tu as besoin de te concentrer
là dessus
bon bien sûr je le fais quand personne
ne me vois pas ce que sinon on prendrait
pour un fou furieux mais je vous assure
c'est un outil qui est extrêmement
puissant on peut le faire à l'écrit
aussi tout simplement écrire tout ce qui
nous passe par la tête de l'extérioriser
ça nous aide à mieux le voir on sort les
poubelles mentale moi le matin je
pratique un exercice qui s'appelle les
pages du matin c'est la première chose
que je fais quand je me réveille et sur
trois pages écrit absolument tout ce qui
me passe par la tête
le pressing qu'il faut que j'aille
chercher le rêve que j'ai eu et ça ça
aide justement avoir son mental et à
décider à quoi est-ce que je vais donner
de l'énergie
et qu'est ce que je vais plutôt mettre
de côté en fonction des buts que je me
fixe pour ma vie
pour illustrer les bienfaits de cette
extériorisation de la pensée par les
poubelles mental imaginez qu'on joue un
jeu j'ai un sac de boules des boules
rouges des boules bleues et je vous
demande de sortir toutes les boules
rouges
cl ça qu'il est opaque savait très
rébarbatif vous allez faire comme ça ça
va prendre des heures mais c'est de ça
qu'il est transparent en deux secondes
vous allez trouver toutes les boules
rouges et le fait de extérioriser
dépensés par rapport à juste garder
dépensé dans la tête et c'est de les
résoudre dans la tête la même différence
qu'entre le sac opaque et sacs
transparents voilà pour les
sèche du bonheur pour conclure je
voudrais vous parler de cette étude
menée par l'université de harvard sur 75
années elle a suivi pendant 75 ans des
personnes et sa grande conclusion sur
qu'est ce qui apporte du bonheur ça va
être une surprise pour personne c'est
que ce qui donne du bonheur c'est les
rapports qu'on entretient avec autrui
mais ce que moi je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est que pour avoir des
bons rapports avec les autres il faut
avant tout avoir un bon rapport avec soi
même et avoir un bon rapport avec soi
même ça suppose de se servir du mental
comme objet par la gratitude par les
poubelles mentale par la méditation
on pose souvent
sion alors est ce que toi tu es heureux
parce que j'ai un blog sur le bonheur et
ma réponse c'est que avant de pratiquer
tout ça j'étais peut-être à 30 % de mes
moments dans le bonheur 70% dans la
résistance et qu'aujourd'hui j'ai
inversé la tendance
je suis plus à 70% dans le bonheur et
30% dans la résistance
parce qu'on peut pas empêcher les
moments de colère et de tristesse mais
on peut réduire leur impact et réduire
leur nombre
et vous quel que soit l'endroit où vous
vous trouvez sur cette distribution
vous avez la possibilité d'augmenter le
nombre de moments de bonheur et de
réduire le nombre de moments de
souffrance
je suis ravie si vous avez trouvé
interressant ce que je vous ai dit ce
soir mais la vérité c'est qu'en fait je
m'en fous un peu d'être intéressant ce
qui compte pour moi c'est d'essayer
d'avoir de l'impact et s'il ya deux
choses que j'aimerais que vous vous
souveniez qu'ils puissent
potentiellement vous affectez c'est
pratiquer la méditation seulement 10
minutes
pratique et la gratitude seulement trois
minutes c'est tout le temps qu'il faut
pour remplir une page avec toutes les
bonnes choses qui vous sont arrivés dans
les 24 dernières heures
si vous faites ça pendant dix jours vous
n'allez pas croire les résultats
votre réalité virtuelle qui veut lui va
complètement changer et si vous le
faites pendant 21 jours ce que nous dit
la science des habitudes c'est que ça
sera devenu une habitude et que vous
aurez plus besoin du pouvoir de votre
volonté pour le mettre en pratique et ça
augmentera significativement le nombre
de moments de bonheur d'acceptation de
l'instant présent que vous avez 7
diminuera le nombre de moments de
résistance à l'instant présent
le nombre de moments de souffrance et je
vous
fait avec cette pensée du dalaï lama qui
dit la chose suivante c'est un acte tu
récolteras une habitude c'est minable
et tu récoltes
caractère c'est maca
r tu récolteras une destinée merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]